invité du 78 à présent François roche
auteur de 24 ouvrage sur l'histoire des
Yvelines bonsoir à vous vous résidez à
cerné à ville merci d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation je le disais 24 livres
sur l'histoire des ivelines qu'est-ce
qui vous fascine autant dans ce
territoire évelinois cela fait 30 ans
que vous publiez régulièrement ces ces
différents ouvrages ces différents tomes
bonsoir Oui euh on s'est installé à
cerner la ville dans la vallée de
Chevreuse en
1970 et en 1984 j'ai publié le premier
tome d'une collection que j'ai appelé la
vallée de Chevreuse et la forêt de
rambouiller en 1900 et qu'est-ce qui m'a
intéressé dans cette région c'est que je
la connaissais pas j'avais jamais vécu
dans les ivelines je connaissais pas les
ivelines et donc on s'est mis à visiter
la région à la parcourir dans tous les
sens c'était l'époque où il y avait pas
encore le parc naturel régional il y
avait pas encore un tourisme
extraordinaire et donc on a découvert
beaucoup d'endroits inconnus insolides
ou oubliés et ces endroits j'ai pu les
retrouver également par la collection de
cartes postales que j'ai réalisé et qui
m'a amené à avoir 10000 cartes postales
sur cette région parce que ces cartes
postales ont parle de carte postal mais
ce qu'il faut bien préciser c'est que ce
sont en fait des clichés donc autant de
témoignages puisque ce sont des photos
de ce qu'on pouvait trouver à l'époque
de ce que les gens voyaient au quotidien
donc ce sont des vrais témoignages
historiques essentiels oui et de plus ce
sont des témoignages objectifs h anné
chch pas à faire deses enisant le phot
d'uneç ou d'une autre il étaient on
pourrait dire naïf et cand il
photographia ce qu'il avait devant eux
et puis c'était c'était terminé donc ce
sont des des témoignages objectifs et et
souvent très émouvants et il faut
préciser que quand on parle de carte
postale ancienne il s'agit de la période
1885 1930 à peu près à cette période là
il y avait pas les moyens de
communication qu'on a aujourd'hui donc
la carte postale était très très très
populaire il y avait parfois trois
distributions de courriers par
jour aujourd'hui c'est tout juste qu' on
en a une les emails ont remplacé les
cartes postales de l'époque voilà voilà
c'est ça et donc ces cartes postales
sont très émouvantes faut penser au
genre de cartes postal qui étent envoyé
par les soldats du front à leur famille
et et et vice-versa donc il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup de cartes postales ce
qui m'a permis de faire une collection
assez rapidement ils sont faciles à
trouver justement vous les avez vous
avez réussi à vous les il y a plusieurs
moyens de trouver les cartes postales
anciennes un c'est d'aller sur les
brocantes et les salons et de les
acheter mais ça revient assez cher
l'autre moyen c'est de rencontrer les
anciens du pays et des villages qui ont
des cartes postales à titre personnel et
qui peuvent les prêter et à ce moment-là
je les recopie et je les rends il y a
aussi un troisième moyen c'est d'aller
dans les endroits comme les archives de
Montin le Bretonneux la bibliothèque de
Versailles et cetera et puis d'emprunter
des clichés avec le accord et de les
reproduire alors donc dans vos ouvrages
on retrouve ces cartes postales est-ce
que vous les avez agrémenté de texte
comment vous avez travaillé ensuite
parce qu'une fois qu'il y a la carte
postale il faut aussi les expliquer les
resituer faire un travail derrière tout
à fait alors le travail consiste à à
grouper les cartes postales par thème à
l'intérieur d'un village donc on parle
d'un village par exemple je prends
cerern la ville on prend les cartes
postales de CERN la ville on les groupe
par thème alors il y a l'église les
auberges la M les fermes et cetera les
moulins et par thème et ensuite pour
chaque thème il faut rédiger un texte
qui prend en compte les cartes postales
chaque carte postale est situé
géographiquement on peut estimer une
date d'après le timbre et l'oblitération
on arrive à estimer une date donc chaque
carte postale est repéré il faut aussi
quand on le peut montrer ce qui est
devenu l'endroit aujourd'hui là c'est
des fois plus triste c'est parfois aussi
très encourageant parce qu'on a retrouvé
des endroits qui avaient pas bougé mais
beaucoup d'endroits ont été é évidemment
ou détruit ou abîmé vos deux derniers
ouvrages trait de Saint-Lambert des bois
mais on la chapelle Mani village et
aussi basoch sur guillonne le trembler
sur moldre et les M Nules quelles sont
les les choses qui vous ont le plus
marqué sur ces territoire là et si vous
deviez vous souvenir de de certains
éléments oui alors c'est une région de
très petits villages c'est d'abord ça le
problème c'est des villages qui ont il
n'ont pas de notoriété historique
extraordinaire et qui ont peu fait
l'objet de recherche donc c'était inant
pour moi de faire des recherches sur ce
village il y a eu des associations
historiques bien sûr mais il y avait pas
eu énormément de de publications ce qui
est intéressant dans ces deux villages
qui sont proches l'un de l'autre c'est
que on y retrouve des traces de
l'occupation romaine h notamment des
voies romaines et une villa galoromaine
à la au ménul qui s'appelle la miliaère
et qui est en train de redisparaître
pour la 3è ou 4e fois dans la forêt elle
avait été redécouverte euh vers 1950 par
François zuubert qui est mort depuis qui
était un grand archéologue de la région
que j'ai rencontré et depuis une dizaine
d'années tout a repoussé on voit plus
rien on voit plus rien et c'était une
villa extraordinaire puisqu'il y avait
des fresqu sur les murs donc c'était une
villa d'un d'un riche patricien romain
avec des fresques et c'est un exemple
unique dans les ivelines c'est dommage
que ce soit en train de disparaître
aujourd'hui vous avez utilisé toutes les
les cartes postales dont vous disposiez
est-ce que vous avez encore d'autres
choses d'autres trésors à publier non je
ne publierai plus rien maintenant parce
que mon souci et mon problème
aujourd'hui c'est de vendre les livres
qui ont été imprimés alors justement où
peut-on se procurer dans les librairies
à nos amant sur 50 ans alors les livres
peuvent être achetés en premier lieu on
peut me téléphoner si on n pas une
librairie en bas de chez soi ce qui est
souvent le cas donc on peut me
téléphoner au
0134 85 21 80 on peut aller à la
librairie du pavé dans la marre à
hencour on peut aller à la librairie de
voisin le
Bretonneux on peut aller à la boutique
du pilote à toussu le noble parce que
j'ai fait deux livres sur l'histoire de
l'aviation dans les ivelines donc c'est
aussi très riche sur ce secteur des
ivlines oui c'était très important on
peut trouver aussi les livres sur les
ménul les basoges dans un endroit
insolite et sympathique c'est le bistr
des ménules h sur la place des ménules
un des derniers bistr tique de la région
et puis bien sûr n'hésitez pas aussi à
nous contacter la chaîne se fera le
relais si vous souhaitez avoir toutes
les les informations pour pouvoir vous
procurer ces différents ouvrages 24 hein
pour retracer l'histoire des evelines
sur cette période il y en a eu 24 mais
10 sont épuisés déjà hein en espérant
une réédition alors non pas de réédition
et ben pas de réédition dommage il
fallait faudra acheter ceuxl alors merci
François roche d'être revenu sur ce